the next presenter. I know Dr. Shomali did an outstanding presentation today at AAM regarding
mastocytosis, what is new in mastocytosis. I'm going to present something very brief about
what is ongoing in selective chemo inhibitors and other targeted therapies in mastocytosis.
Mastocytosis is certainly a very exciting disease in the way that it's a complex group of disorders
where from the majority of the times we had patients with indolent disease or non-advanced
mastocytosis, in 20-30% of the cases we had advanced disease, including the combination
of systemic mastocytosis and associated hematological neoplasm. But what I'm going
to do is to present the two most recent studies where we are basically having information about
results and hopefully FDA approval. One of them is pesuclastinib that was presented by Dr. Rain
and Dr. Shomali. And I'm going to present the two most recent studies where we are basically
in December. This is a study that eventually compared in a randomization 2-to-1 pesuclastinib
versus placebo in 179 patients with indolent systemic mastocytosis, specifically for the
purpose of evaluating a mean change in the baseline symptoms with reduction in some biomarkers,
including serone triptase, bone marrow muscle burden, and a KIT reduction.
The primary point for the summit was met at 24 weeks, where there is a significant reduction
in the symptom score, where the symptom score that were worse eventually get better after 24
weeks of current treatment with pesuclastinib treatment. And this is significant with the
p-value that is demonstrated over here. When the results were evaluated according to different
group of symptoms, all of the symptoms in general got benefit with the addition of pesuclastinib,
including neurocognitive symptoms, skin, and constitutional symptoms such as fatigue.
And I just mentioned one slide of the bone marrow muscle burden that notably achieved
significant reduction. In fact, it was one of the reasons for presentation at us regarding
the pathological response in pesuclastinib for those patients treated with indolent systemic
mastocytosis.
The safety profile was relatively remarkable towards no major significant side effects,
with exception of LFT elevations that in a number of cases were transient and returning
to the baseline after decreasing the dose or holding the medication temporarily.
So this is the data that I show in indolent. Certainly, we have other results, especially
in advanced mastocytosis.
And this is the preliminary information for APEX. Some of the results that I am showing
you are going to be, are already submitted to IHA in 2026. We're just waiting for approval
for presentation. But this is the study designed and where it's at part one and part two, which
is primarily the expansion. I'm going to mention a few variables only. The total number of
patients that were recruited for the advanced systemic mastocytosis are 81 with distribution
towards more.
For indolent systemic mastocytosis with AHN versus advanced or mass leukemias, the overall
response rate was 57%, but the pure pathological response was 88%. And over here, you see the
different responses, partial remission, the pathological response criteria, and the median
time to respond, which is approximately two months. And similar to the results in the
indolent mastocytosis,
this cohort, the serone treatase, bone marrow, muscle burden, and kidney mutation were significantly
declined. Bringing the progression-free survival is significantly meaningful, but there will
be certainly more data released at IHA. A subset of patients in the APEX study are using
the concurrent combination of azacitidine with vasoclastinib, where patients are treated
with acetylcholine, adenophenol, and adenophenol with a C-MML or MDS, combining vasoclastinib with a standard dose of azacitidine. The study is currently ongoing and will finalize the recruitment of the patients at the end of this year.
What are other ongoing studies in ISM? Two important studies that are ongoing. L-anestinib, which is part of the Harvard clinical trial, and the other is the TELIOS, the TLA-95. This is a study where the part one is already completed, and the other is the TLA-95.
The study is currently ongoing and will finalize the recruitment of the patients at the end of this year. The study is currently ongoing and will finalize the recruitment of the patients at the end of this year.
The study is currently ongoing and will finalize the recruitment of the patients at the end of this year. The study is currently ongoing and will finalize the recruitment of the patients at the end of this year. The study is currently ongoing and will finalize the recruitment of the patients at the end of this year.
mutated disease needs certainly better studies, global access. A number of companies are already
extending clinical trials to different parts of the world. And the possibility of expanded
asset studies, integration of real-world data, and molecular guided therapy. Thank you very much for
your time. Thanks.